on cherche la femme la plus sexy
d'autres entreprises ah bon
selon votre ami vous êtes la plus sexy
l'entreprise a beau oui qu'est ce que
l'on veut sauver plaisir oui bien sûr
ouais ben koldyke ce n'est toi je le
sais si mon niveau je me monique parce
qu'on manque quelque chose de l'animal
qui dégagent une envie tout de suite de
faire l'amour pourquoi pas c'est très
attirant fait un angle sexy alors je
vais vous présenter la bête de sectes la
bête de sexe et vous savez sûrement
qu'on a voulu bien me plaît c'est comme
ça qu'il ment il aime les femmes
il aime énormément les face au lieu de
se dire bon c'est vrai que mon fantasme
ne l'avoir n'est ce pas une fois les
dents même la peau et ses oiseaux surgit
vraiment plus loin le plus loin une loi
que ça ouais ah oui et ça vous fait
plaisir en banque la plus sexy il est
vraiment sexy movie ouais il est tombé
quand on peut devoir dessiner aux femmes
avec la cambrure naturel hélas cette
grâce nature à une grasse matinée
ouais
et vous dans votre entreprise vous êtes
imposé ces questions là demain
questionné dans le tour deux jours et
vous verrez vous aurez des surprises